We know Jupiter is nothing like Earth.
It’s a massive gas giant -- 600 million km away.
Jupiter’s upper cloud layer is composed
almost entirely of hydrogen and helium.
But we don’t know much about what goes on
under this obscuring layer.
In 2011, NASA launched the spacecraft, Juno,
on a 5-year-long trip
to investigate Jupiter's deep structures.
In 2016, Juno reached Jupiter
and began a series of orbits that revealed Jupiter’s
poles for the first time.
Images captured by the JunoCam
show the characteristic color banding of the equator
giving way to clusters of cyclonic storms,
some of them up to 1,400 km across.
At the equator,
the craft spotted an unexpected plume of ammonia
rising above the planet’s gassy surface.
Juno has also been using its
onboard microwave radiometer
to peer deep below Jupiter’s
upper cloud layer,
where pressures can be
hundreds of times stronger than on Earth.
Jupiter’s atmosphere is not well mixed--
there are structures deep
under the outer cloud layer
and they don’t line up with the bands
we’ve been able to see until now.
Here is a first look at Jupiter’s southern auroras
captured by the spacecraft.
The behavior of auroras on Earth
is largely dictated by the sun,
but findings suggest that Jupiter’s magnetic field
is up to 50% stronger
than expected in some areas and may
be affected by the planet’s own rotation.
Juno has only completed 6 orbits so far,
but already the data is showing that our understanding
of gas giants may not line up with reality.
Up next Juno will set its sights
on one of Jupiter’s most mysterious features
the Big Red Spot.
In July 2017, Juno will do a flyby of the giant storm,
hoping to shed some light on its origins,
how it is maintained, and just how far down it goes.
The spacecraft’s mission will come to an end
in early 2018, when it will intentionally
crash into Jupiter’s upper atmosphere.
Until then,
Juno will be collecting massive amounts of data,
which will not only give us a better understanding of
Jupiter’s origins, but maybe even offer a glimpse
at how the solar system came to be.